all right y'all we're back and i'm
hanging with paul lapel sara bareilles
busy phillips and renee elise goldsberry
give it up
together they play a girl group in the
new show girls five eva on peacock
um so it's time to find out y'all um who
you'd be in the girl group in real life
so um i'll give you one question uh to
each of you
but then you all should answer after
that person answers get it
i think you get i think so yeah i think
you follow
all right here we go busy who in the
group
trips walking out on stage well
our dear paul lapel and me but
paula you just knocked over a he just
walked over two stands
i'm very i'm i'm i'm not
a graceful person i ride low like fog i
just kind of fill
in the spaces and uh if something's in
the way it's going down
so she knows how to make an entrance
that's what it is
i ride low like fog i'm very solid
i i hold my gravity very low yeah
okay so wait sarah who do you think is
the most
you know most likely to trip well i
don't know i
i i guess i would agree that you know
i think we all have really clumsy ones
i'm honestly just it's
popped in my mind when when busy
hit renee in the face with the salad
bowl
what
yeah we were shooting a scene in a
closet
and uh there was a gag where she was
supposed to you know
spill toss the salad as it were and uh
the next thing i know i was like god
oh my gosh okay so then that
of me talking like this is still in it
but like renee keeps asking
us like you guys is it bad is it bad and
it's like our lip is
like four times the size and we're just
like no it's fine it looks great
yeah and i i walked in after the whole
thing happened and it was a very weird
energy on the set everyone was
whispering
she had a giant bag of ice on her face
and busy was kind of pacing around
see this is what i imagine girl groups
are like
it was very funny i know you can't laugh
until later but then you laugh
hysterically
you've been holding it for a minute
because you wanted to laugh before um
so paula who in the group curses on
stage uh
well i would say busy and i probably are
the foulest mouths of these four
beauties um i was on when we did wine
country we went on the today show and
within 30 seconds i said
the s word oh
they frown upon that i've slipped before
yeah i mean like immediately
i think it was the first thing i uttered
and it was just one of those like
somebody said something amazing and i
went
and i just said it and everyone looked
at me like i had
you know killed someone pooped in their
purse and i was like
i am very sorry i guess i can't say that
on the today show in the mornings and my
mother was watching so
but i think busy and i are both pretty
unfiltered when it comes to vocabulary
like that
i'm unfiltered too but do you all feel
like you you well first of all i feel
like i became unfiltered when i was a
waitress because
there were four letter words were the
only ones that felt good right
saying um but i don't ever say it really
in anger
mine's like i just i'm in conversation
i'm like i always i usually say it
either
in in joy or every so often if i'm
really frustrated about something i'll
i'll use a good juicy word but a lot of
times you just
it just becomes part of your vernacular
of just
yeah of joyful telling a story
or whatever i get it i get it busy you
too you got a potty mouth
yeah same i have you know it's hard for
me
i just enjoy saying the words
i do too my mother can't stand the f
word i know
whatever but it's sorry mom it's
literally one of my favorite words
you know
you come from a long line of what i come
from a long line of women that curse and
i'm kind of proud of that i'm kind of
proud of it i think there's something
beautiful a woman
about a woman that's that doesn't like
feel like she has to censor her emotion
and how it comes out of her mouth
i think that's very lazy i i hope my mom
we're going to keep this in so she hears
that
um she yes she doesn't appreciate it as
much as
us so renee who's the leader of the
group
uh well in terms of the uh gosh you know
there's a really
we're all very strong but there is one
of us
who is the ringleader especially when it
comes to doing something
uh important or amazing or amazing are
celebrating each other and that is busy
phillips yes
she is always like you know 20 steps
ahead
she just like we we shot this show i'm
glad we hit christmas we hit you know
new year's we had a lot of birthdays
and you know way before anybody can
think about it this girl has an idea
to make some merch we have girls fight
out about everything
uh just because she's gonna find a way
to give a present
what that's been thought of that
celebrates somebody amazing
uh to everybody in the cast and crew you
know and the worst part
is she always makes sure we all want to
go in on it for her but she never takes
our money afterwards
we don't know her venmo so if anyone
knows her venmo
out in in the viewing audience please
send it to us because we
listen i get requests every day from
random people so i feel like you can
probably find it
i'll always take the lead i'll always
pick the gifts that's
i love doing it i do too i think i'm
that person in my group i love it
i think mine comes from like i always
felt bad when like in childhood like
when anybody felt left out so i never
wanted anybody to not be included so i
like try and go now my friends will say
i go
way too above and beyond and then i
stress myself out doing it
as i'm learning in therapy but um but
yeah
but i think but i think it's a really
it's a nice thing though you're trying
to make everybody feel like welcome and
a part of something
and i love being a part of a team so um
well we are out of time right now thank
you so much ladies um
you can watch all episodes of girls five
on peacock starting tomorrow
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever